[Musik]
und jetzt das heute
journal guten Abend der Skandal um das
Hilfswerk der Vereinten Nationen im
Gazastreifen zieht weitere Kreise
während der UN Generalsekretär versucht
die Finanzierung der Organisation zu
retten die Enthüllungen über
hamasverbindungen von un Mitarbeitern
werfen auch ein Schlaglicht darauf unter
welchen Bedingungen solche hilfs
vor Ort arbeiten es ist halt nicht so
dass die tausenden Mitarbeiter dort
größtenteils aus neutralen Drittstaaten
stammen also z.B Norweger mit unmütze
Lebensmittel verteilen oder an
schulenunterrichten die meisten sind
Einheimische und das kann zu den
komplizenschaften führen über die jetzt
weithin berichtet wird Benjamin
Daniel me Verteilen an jene die es
dringend brauchen Aufnahmen von hern des
un palästinenserhilfswerks in Rafa Gaza
viele hier haben Angst vor dem Szenario
dass die Hilfe wegbrechen
könnte die westlichen Länder sind alle
gegen uns hier in Gaza das ist eine
Verschwörung ein Todesurteil wenn das
Hilfswerk seine Aktivitäten einstellt
werden wir in den Straßen
verhungern der Druck auf die Vereinten
Nationen wächst zunächst war die Rede
von Z Mitarbeitern die am hamasterror
vom 7 Oktober beteiligt gewesen sein
dann berichtet das Wall Street Journal
dass etwa 10% aller rund 12000
Angestellten des Hilfswerks in Gaza
Verbindungen zuur Hamas oder dem
islamistischen Jihad haben sollen das
palästinenserhilfswerk stellt Israel
regelmäßig Listen seiner Mitarbeiter zur
Verfügung wie es trotzdem zu diesem
Skandal kommen konnte wird untersucht
die usbotschafterin bei den Vereinten
Nationen fordert schnelle und gründliche
Aufarbeitung wir müssen die Organisation
genau unter die Lupe nehmen wie sie in
Gaza handelt wie das
Mitarbeitermanagement läuft außerdem
müssen wir sicherstellen dass jene die
kriminelle Handlungen vollziehen wie die
Z genannten unverzüglich zur
Rechenschaft gezogen werden sodass die
Organisation ihre wichtige Arbeit
fortsetzen
kann der UN Generalsekretär will sich
noch heute mit Vertretern der
Geberländer treffen trotz des Skandals
wird er versuchen möglichst viele dazu
zu bewegen das Aussetzen der
Hilfszahlungen wieder rückgängig zu
machen wird alles andere als einfach
denn die Vorwürfe biegen
schwer nach Deutschland es ist
haushaltswoche im Bundestag
normalerweise hätte diese abschließende
Debatte im November stattgefunden damit
vor Weihnachten der Haushalt fürs
darauffolgende Jahr beschlossen ist
diesmal brauchte es länger aus bekannten
Gründen erst Streit in der Ampel dann
kam das Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts das einen
roten Strich durch manche Rechnung
machte danach war noch mehr Druck im
Kessel Frank Buchwald hat den
debattenauftakt heute
beobachtet ein Haushalt mit Hindernissen
auch heute im Parlament der Gong ist
kaputt das Mikro geht nicht
läuft monatelang hat die Ampel um den et
gerungen nach dem Veto aus Karlsruhe von
sparen jedoch keine Spur kritisiert die
Union wir leben massiv über die
Verhältnisse ihr Haushalt ist weit von
einer sparanstrengung oder einem
Sparhaushalt entfernt um das ganz klar
zu sagen der Entwurf hat ein Volumen von
476,8 Milliarden Euro 31,1 Milliarden
mehr als ursprünglich geplant die
Neuverschuldung steigt um
22,5 auf jetzt 39 Milliarden haarscharf
im Rahmen der Schuldenbremse diese
Bundesregierung und die sie tragende
Koalition wir investieren in schiine
Straße und digitale
aufordniveau die Summe der Investitionen
steigt auf 70,5 Milliarden 16,3
Milliarden mehr als im ersten Entwurf
der AFD aber passt die ganze Richtung
nicht es ist ein erbärmliches Schauspiel
man belastet deutsche Landwirte und
Fischer während unzählige Milliarden für
Ausland Krieg und Klima nach wie vor
verschleudert werden die AFD will
deshalb klagen eine Mehrheit dafür aber
hat sie nicht weiter uneins ist die
Ampel über die Schuldenbremse SPD und
Grüne wollen sie notfalls noch einmal
aussetzen etwa wenn die Ukraine Hilfe
braucht und deshalb auch die klare
Botschaft dieses Haushaltes mit 8
Milliarden Euro wir lassen die
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer in ihrem
Freiheitskampf nicht alleine
haushaltswoche im Bundestag der große
Showdown aber steht erst morgen an in
der
Generaldebatte wie es in der Ukraine
weiter geht es in der Tat
unabsehbar auch unter den Ukrainern hat
sich Ernüchterung breit gemacht darüber
wie lange dieser Krieg noch dauern wird
und anders als in Russland wird in der
Ukraine darüber auch offen gesprochen so
wurde in den letzten Monaten intensiv
darüber diskutiert wie neue Soldaten
mobilisiert werden dazu hat das Kabinett
dem Parlament heute einen neuen
Vorschlag vorgelegt Präsident zelenski
kann und will jedenfalls nicht einfach
zwangsrekrutieren wie Putin das tun kann
der sich zudem keine Sorgen darüber
machen muss wie es seinen Soldaten an
der frontergeht offene Kritik hat er
nicht zu befürchten in der Ukraine
hingegen rührt sich zunehmend Protest
dagegen dass viele Soldaten seit bald
zwe Jahren im Dauereinsatz sind eine brü
berichtet militärleute sind keine
Sklaven rufen die Frauen auf dem Maidan
in Kiev seit Wochen kommen sie hierher
um für gerechtere Regeln für die zu
kämpfen die ihr Land als Soldaten
verteidigen wenn man sich hier umschaut
dann sieht man hier viele poelle
Wehrpflichtige das Land müssen alle
verteidigen und nicht nur die die in den
ersten Tagen zur Front gegangen
sind sie alle haben Söhne Brüder Männer
an der Front und sie alle wissen um die
Gefahren neue Regeln zur Mobilmachung
hatte die Regierung angekündigt bis der
Vorschlag durchs Parlament geht könnte
es
dauern wir kritisieren nicht unsere
Regierung wir kritisieren auch nicht
unsere Streitkräfte wir stehen hier für
unsere
Männer keiner weiß wie lange dieser
Krieg noch dauern wird es ist wichtig
für die gesamte Gesellschaft viele neue
Leute werden noch einberufen und auch
für sie ist eine solche Beschränkung
wichtig bislang ist der Kriegsdienst
zeitlich nicht befristet die Regeln für
die Einberufung intransparent und mit
Ausnahmen die Last dieses Krieges sagen
die Frauen muss auf vielen Schultern
verteilt
werden jetzt ist es für andere an derit
gerpflicht zu erfüllen das Land
verteidigen die Herausforderung annehmen
für das eigene Land zu kämpfen für sein
Volk für den friedlichen Himmel über den
Köpfen unserer Kinder für eine
friedliche
Zukunft dass das noch ein langer und
schwieriger Weg ist das wissen sie
auch zur Lage in der Ukraine will das
heute journal Update nachher
Alexandra sprechen ihre Organisation
Center for civil liberties erhielt
vorletztes Jahr den Friedens
Nobelpreis jetzt macht he Wolf weiter
mit anderen Nachrichten des Tages die
Gewerkschaft werdi ruft zu weiteren
Warnstreiks auf und zwar bei den
luftsicherheitskräften an mehreren
deutschen Flughäfen am Donnerstag
betroffen sind dem nach elf Flughäfen
darunter Frankfurt am Main Berlin
Stuttgart und Hamburg laut werdi konnte
bei den bisherigen
tarifverhandlungsrunden über
Lohnerhöhungen keine Einigung erzielt
werden tausende Ärztinnen und Ärzte sind
einem Aufruf des Marburger Bundes
gefolgt und haben ihre Arbeit an
zahlreichen Unikliniken niedergelegt
allein 5000 Mediziner sollen sich an der
zentralen Kundgebung in Hannover
beteiligt haben hintergrund sind die
bislang ergebnislosen Tarifverhandlungen
mit den Ländern der Marburger Bund
fordert 12,5% mehr Gehalt und bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen während
Finanzminister Lindner bei den
Haushaltsberatungen im Bundestag die
Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse betont hat
geht die Diskussion über eine Lockerung
dieser Schuldenbremse weiter die
Wirtschaftsweisen haben sich heute für
eine Reform ausgesprochen in ihrer
aktuellen Ausgestaltung sei die
Schuldenbremse starrer als notwendig so
das Gremium dass die Regierung
berätt und Deutschlands Wirtschaft ist
im letzten Quartal des vergangenen
Jahres geschrumpft das Statistische
Bundesamt hat für das
Bruttoinlandsprodukt ein Minus von
0,3% im Vergleich gleich zum Vorquartal
errechnet ein besonders starker Rückgang
nachdem die Wirtschaft in den ersten
drei Quartalen in etwa stagnierte so die
Statistiker und noch kurz die
Wetteraussichten morgen im Osten noch
Regen ansonsten lockert es auf und vor
allem im Südwesten scheint die Sonne oft
an der Küste weht der Wind stürmisch um
Südwest höchste Temperaturen bei 6 bis
13° in den nächsten Tagen wird es wieder
wechselhafter mit Regen und Wind bei
maximal 5 bis 13° bleibt es weiterhin zu
mild für diese
Jahreszeit das war's auch schon von uns
in dieser Halbzeitpause und gegen 01
meldet sich dann Gundula Gause mit
unserem heute Schal Update auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
wiedersehen